API Connect video series this
presentation will show you how to create
a REST API to age so a service begin
this construction by logging into the
dashboard of your API connect management
portal click the menu icon and then
click draft
once you arrive at the draft screen
click on api's click + to add a new API
in the ensuing dialogue box
enter a title for the new API and then
click Add this brings you to the design
screen for the new API going down the
screen we come to schemes which we must
use HTTP if we are going to use this on
bluemix or any public cloud this will
consume application JSON and produce
application JSON as opposed to the XML
that the backend Sowa is expecting we
leave the security definitions in place
this will require any application to
provide an IBM client ID under paths
which is the path that the user of the
API will invoke we will change that to
something that we will then publish to
the users of this new REST API they will
never see the real URL of the actual
back-end
this currently instead of by default
doesn't get however because this is a so
a back-end we do want a post rather than
a get and we will not use to get so we
delete it we now must create a set of
services that actually represent the
backend we do this by uploading a wisdom
file here we look at the actual wisdom
file and we see under the window
definitions the namespace of the backend
so a resource and a check request XS d
and a check response XS d for now
however all we need to do is upload the
wisdom and the Wizzle is parsed
automatically and shows you the services
that are available we pick the one
service that we want to use here this
automatically creates two services an
account inquiry in a check requests
which are defined in the wisdom now we
go create the definitions that are based
on the inbound JSON payload we begin to
create the name of the definition which
in this particular case will be the JSON
check request and now we must populate
the name of this object with the various
properties
so we start by defining the first of the
properties here we see the inbound JSON
payload for reference
create all of these properties in the
definition that we are creating for the
API Connect so here we create pay or
account name
now I'm not going to show you how we do
all of these you can understand how you
make those when you're all done it'll
look something like this notice that
this continues to add new properties to
the top of the list rather than the
bottom of the list will now create the
definition for the response just as
before we see an example of what the
JSON tech response is that we want to
send to the original caller of the API
so we have a Czech response and once
again we walk through the elements that
are in the outbound JSON payload one by
one and create these properties and we
will walk through all of those
particular steps once you're done you
have these two definitions check
response and check request and we have
these two services that came from the
Wizzle
now we assemble our API logic click
assemble and then on the assemble screen
click DataPower then remove the invoke
that we will not use once you create a
service you can now simply drag the
service up onto the assembly line and
because it knows that you created this
service from a Wizzle that represents a
back-end service it automatically
creates the two Maps the maps translate
the or map the JSON elements that come
from the request to the XML elements
that the backend so a service is
expecting and here you can see that
there's quite a list of these possible
objects that again came from the wisdom
but we want the one that we created here
we are now at the input map you'll
notice on the left is the definition we
created and on the right is the XML
definition that came out of the whistle
now we simply drag and connect the
various elements together
we have to repeat this process in order
to do the back end or Rosario in order
to deal with the response coming from
the back end once the Scylla back end
has responded so we proceed the same way
we create the maps using the
drag-and-drop capabilities of the user
interface
once this is complete we can now go and
arrange to setup the actual invocation
which is in between the two minutes it's
a good idea to save it first so that the
invocation can show you any warnings and
happen to be there the target URL is
coming directly out of the whistle you
may need to change this URL depending on
how you've built your back-end or where
you placed your back-end an examination
of the remaining input to the invoke
show that we are only using the defaults
click all ap is in the upper left hand
corner to return to the list of all
available API
your new ref to sellout API is now
available to publish in any product that
you choose
you